when I first met Joe pre-jk the glory
did something and what's his house to
meet up and it sounded like he had a
party over he opens the door and I go
inside and I realized he was just
talking to himself the whole time loud
enough for you to hear on the outside
dude I would be [__] terrified
2003 2004. I rolled up he has his inner
black comedian talking to his inner
Vietnamese guy
what the hell and just going back and
forth this is during the days where the
back of the monitors are still this big
you know what I'm talking about that's
how you dated or he is one of the
greatest actors of our time he sees you
coming through the blinds he gets his
[__] [__] going he's been playing
this character for a decade like the
prestige could be maybe I don't know